البحر العلاقات بين بكين وواشنطن لا يهدا
ملف تايوان الابرز في واجهه الصراع ويكشف
الكثير من الخبايا رغم تاريخها البحري
الممتد لطالما اعتبرت الولايات المتحده
الصين قوه بريه بامتياز وضعيفه الى حد
بعيد على مستوى البحر غير ان الوقائع تقول
عكس ذلك المعادله تغيرت فمنذ حوالي عقد من
الزمن بدات الصين مرحله جديده من تطوير
قوتها العسكريه البحريه حيث انتقلت من صفر
حاملات طائرات الى ثلاث واخرى في طور
البناء البحريه الصينيه اقدمت ايضا على
تحديث الكثير من قدرات المراقبه البحريه
لتلائم قدرات الاخرين كما انشات بكين
علاقات جديده مع القوى الاقليميه حيث تفتح
موانئ لسفنها الحربيه لزياره اماكن بعيده
كباب وغينيا الجديده في جنوب المحيط
الهادئ بالقرب من سواحل استراليا الصين
ايضا لانشاء قاعده بحريه كبيره على طول
الساحل الشرقي لافريقيا حتى تتمكن من
الحصول على موقع دائم على طول ساحل المحيط
الاطلسي يقول خبراء انه بمجرد ان تتمكن
الصين من تامين سيطرتها على المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ فانها ستطور اسطولها
البحريه لتكون قوه اكبر وبعد ان تعزز
قبضتها على المنطقه يمكنها ان تندفع خارج
نطاق نفوذها وتبدا التدخل في نصف الكره
الغربي وهو مجال نفوذ واشنطن التقليدي
بلال الوجداني العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات